ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAN. BENNETT BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA. BRIAN CALDERON. CARRILLO
CERVANTES JUNE. CHOI COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY. DAILY
DAVIES FLORA MIKE FONG. VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN. GABRIEL
GALLAGHER. CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES
SAWYER. KALRA KILEY. BLACKY LEE.
LEVINE LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES MCCARTY. MEDINA MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN. WIND
TUNNEL. PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
QUOTE. QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO. SALAS SANTIAGO
SEYARTO SMITH. STONE TAKING.
BALLOT ERRORS THE APPROVED.
VOEPEL WALDRON. WARD WEBER.
WICKS WORD. MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAZE PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN IMAM IS. AND THE NAME OF
GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. INTERNAL GUARD. WE
LIVED HEARTS FULL OF GRATITUDE
TO YOU ON THIS DAY THAT YOU HAVE
MADE. THANKING YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO REJOICE. AND BE
GLAD IN IT. WE GIVE THANKS FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. MAKE YOUR PRESENCE AND
YOUR PURPOSE COME ALIVE IN THEIR
DELIBERATIONS AND DEBATES TODAY
. BY YOUR WILL PLEASE EMPOWER
THEIR LEADERSHIP. AND
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THROUGH THEM
EXTEND YOUR BLESSING TO EVERY
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES HERE TODAY. YOUR
GRACE TO THOSE WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION YOUR EQUITY TO
THE POOR YOUR PEACE TO THE
TROUBLED. YOUR LIGHT TO THOSE IN
DESPAIR GRANT US ALL FULL ACCESS
TO THE HEALING RESOURCES AND
RECONCILING JUSTICE YOU HAVE
ORDAINED FOR US. IN YOUR NAME WE
PRAY I MEAN. YES SIR YES
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BETTER AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER BENNETT. MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE.
READY BEGIN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAIRMAN SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY
MARCH SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TO
THE ASSEMBLY MET AT SEVEN AM THE
AUDIBLE MARC LEVINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TENTH DISTRICT CITING TWO
CLERKS WHO PROGRAM THE DESK
CLERK DAVID ONLY RAMOS MOVES AND
MR GALLAGHER SECONDS. AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR A
FAMILY FUNERAL ASSMBLY MEMBER
SALAS. MS REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW SPEAKER
RENDON AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY BONTA KALRA QUIRK
AND WORD TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX AND RE REFER THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE. AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX STONE FROM
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. AB
SEVENTY NO WAY KILEY FROM THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
CAN PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE AND
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. AB
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE GRAYSON
FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE. THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE AND THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. AB NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR MIKE FONG FROM THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY FIVE OH SIX. WORK FROM
THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY TWO RUBIO FROM THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
FOR THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
REVENUE TAXATION COMMITTEE. AND
THE AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
GRAYSON FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. THE CHIEF JUSTICE HAS
TRANSMITTED A TRANSCRIPT OF THE
STATE OF THE JUDICIARY ADDRESS
IT IS AT THE DESK I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO PRINT THE
ADDRESS IN THE JOURNAL AS AN
APPENDIX. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA THE
FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
HERE AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
GRAYSON. ON MONDAY MARCH TWENTY
EIGHT AT A TIME TO BE ANNOUNCED
. AND AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULES SEVENTY
SEVEN AND SIXTY THREE. THE TAKE
UP AB SEVEN SIX NINE GRAYSON
TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE
IN SENATE AMENDMENTS. AND AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MISS DAVIES FOR WHAT. MISS DAVIS WHAT PURPOSE IN
ORDER TO SPEND THE STATE GAS TAX
AND SAFE EVERY CALIFORNIA
FIFTEEN CENTS A GALLON I MOVE TO
SUSPEND THE RULES IN ORDER TO
TAKE UP EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY THREE
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. MISS
DAVIES YOU'RE YOU'RE OUT OF
ORDER YOU SPOKE ON THE SEVENTH
SO THE MATTER BEFORE THE MOTION
GIVE A MOTION BEFORE THE BODY. I
MAKE A MOTION TO SUSPEND THE
RULES IN ORDER TO TAKE UP AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WITH A
REFERENCE TO FILE. MISS DAVIS
THAT REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS.
MISS DAVIES THE MOTION IS OUT OF
ORDER BECAUSE THE BILL HAS BEEN
REFERRED TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. YEAH. MISS DAVIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ALTHOUGH THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED TO THE COMMITTEE
WE ASK THAT WE WORK THIS BILL.
TO MISS DAVIES ON THE MOTION THE
MOTION TO. WITHDRAW THE BILL
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE UNDER RULE ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX ALL MOTIONS TO
WITHDRAW OUR AMOUNT
AUTOMATICALLY REFERRED. WITHOUT
DEBATE OR VOTE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. SO THE CLERK WILL
NOTE. WE ARE MOVING YES MISS
DAVIS IS TO FILE WE MOVE IT TO
THE FLOOR. I'M SORRY. FILE. THE
MOTION IS TO MOVE THE BILL BILL
TO THE FLOOR WITHOUT REFERENCE
OF FILE.
AND THEN SOME IS DAVIS I HAVE
ADDRESS THAT MATTER PROPERLY.
YES MISS AGUIAR-CURRY WHAT
PURPOSE. ACR. ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
MR GALLAGHER FOR PURPOSE SIR.
SPEAKER STATION POINT OF ORDER.
BUT THERE WAS A MOTION TO MOVE
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE I BELIEVE THAT
MOTION IS IN ORDER. THIS IS THE
BILL TO SUSPEND THE STATE'S GAS
TAX. THE BILL HAS BEEN REFERRED
TO THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
SHE GALLAGHER THE MOTION TO
REFER THE BILL HAS BEEN REFERRED
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE SO THE
CLERK WILL NOT. TO THE POINT OF
ORDER IS NOT WELL TAKEN MISTER
GALLAGHER. MR GALLAGHER
INSTRUMENTS GALLAGHER MY PHONE
ON- MR GALLAGHER FOR PURPOSE SIR.
MISTER SPEAKER WE WOULD MOVE TO
SUSPEND. ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX IN ORDER TO MOVE THIS BILL
TO THE FLOOR WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE.
MR GALLAGHER. THE MOTION TO
WITHDRAW HAS BEEN PROPERLY
REFERRED REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. AS I HAVE PREVIOUSLY
INDICATED MULTIPLE TIMES NOW AT
THIS POINT WE ARE READY TO MOVE
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING. SECOND READING
CORPORATION. SENATE BILL.
NINETEEN FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
NINETY EIGHT NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN THE MEMBERS TWENTY FORTY
WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE OF THE MEMBERS EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE MEMBERS TWENTY
THREE TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN OH
NINE WITH A MINUTE SIXTY SEVEN
THREE OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY TO
EIGHTY WITHIN MINUTES EIGHTEEN
SIXTY WITH HIM IT'S EIGHTEEN
FIFTY TWO THE MINUTES SEVENTEEN
NINETY EIGHT WITH A MEMBERS
TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN OF THE
MINUTES NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE
MINUTES SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH A MINUTE SIXTY FORTY TWO OF
THE MEMBERS TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN OF THE MEMBERS. TWENTY SIX
OR SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE MINUTES NINETEEN
THIRTY TO TWENTY TO FORTY FOR
THE MOMENT SEVENTY SEVEN SIX THE
MENDOCINO FOR THE MINUTES AND
SENATE BILL TWO OH SEVEN WITH A
MINUTES ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WERE MOVING.
BUSINESS THE DAILY. FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX SHALL BE CONTINUED.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM THIRTY. THIS IS ACR
ONE FIFTY EIGHT THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO WOMEN IN AGRICULTURE
MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. ACR ONE FIFTY EIGHT
HONORS THE IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTIONS OF WOMEN IN
AGRICULTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WOMEN HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN REGRET
RELEGATED TO LESS VISIBLE ROLES
IN AGRICULTURE BUT THEY HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN CRITICAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES AND FOOD PRODUCTION
. FEMALE PRODUCERS DR LOCAL
ECONOMIES THEY OWN SMALLER FARMS
THAT GROW MORE DIVERSIFIED CROPS
THAT ARE MORE RACIALLY DIVERSE
AND SELL MORE DIRECTLY TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES THAN THEIR MALE
COUNTERPARTS. WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
MANY WHO RESIDE IN THE SOVEREIGN
NATIONS REPRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FOR IN ACROSS THE STATE
ARE ALSO PLAYING A CENTRAL ROLE
IN STEWARDING LAND PRODUCING
FOOD AND PLAYING IN A AND- AND
CARING ON TRADITIONAL CULTURAL
PRACTICES THE SUPPORT OUR STATE
ECOSYSTEMS AND FOOD SECURITY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
THE VALUE OF ALL WOMEN'S
CONTRIBUTIONS TO AGRICULTURE AND
RESOLVE TO HELP THEM TO CONTINUE
TO LEAD AND SUPPORT THEIR
COMMUNITIES THROUGH THIS WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
. LOCAL FOR THE ROLE I'M SORRY
THIS CITIES YOU ARE STILL GOING
TO TAKE- CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CORPORAL. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLICK ON CLOSE RATHER
SEVENTY CO AUTHORS ADDED. AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY DAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
THESE ARE GUESTS IN THE GALLERY
IN RECOGNITION OF WOMEN'S
CONTRIBUTIONS TO AGRICULTURE ON
BEHALF OF AG ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY LET'S WELCOME THEM
FORMALLY TO THE ASSEMBLY.
MR GALLAGHER PLEASE TAKE TWENTY
WATER. YES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND RESPECTFULLY WHEN WE
WERE IN MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
THERE WAS NEVER RULING ON MY
MOTION. TO SUSPEND RULE NINETY
SIX SO THAT WE COULD- MOVE THE
BILL FROM COMMITTEE- TO THE
FLOOR AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT.
MS REYES SAGE POINT OF ORDER
WE'RE NO LONGER IN MY EMOTIONS
WE HAVE ALREADY CONTINUED ON TO
BUSINESS OF THE DAY.
IS RAISE YOUR POINT OF ORDER IS
WELL TAKEN. MR GALLAGHER I
APPEAL THE DECISION OF THE CHAIR. ON THE APPEAL THE DECISION OF
THE CHAIR. THAT HAS BEEN
SECONDED MR GALLAGHER YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES ON WHETHER THE
RULING OF THE CHAIR SHOULD BE
SUSTAINED. MR GALLAGHER THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER WHAT I WHAT I%
HAD. THE MOTION THAT I MADE WAS
TO SUSPEND OUR RULES
SPECIFICALLY RULE NINETY SIX SO
THAT WE COULD BRING AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT TO THE FLOOR NOW
NORMALLY I WOULDN'T ASK FOR A
SUSPENSION OF THE RULES WE HAVE
AN URGENT CRISIS ON OUR HANDS
AND A GAS PRICES ARE AT ALL TIME
HIGH. NOW OVER SIX DOLLARS A
GALLON AND OUR OUR PEOPLE NEED
DESPERATE DESPERATELY NEED
RELIEF NOW. STATE YOUR POINT OF
ORDER. STAGE POINT WHERE MISS
RAND'S GALLAGHER SHOULD SPEAK TO
THE MERITS OF HIS APPEAL WHICH
IS ON THE RULES THEMSELVES NOT
ON WHATEVER THE BILL IS. THAT
POINT OF ORDER IS WELL TAKEN
MISTER GALLAGHER THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
POLICY THIS IS ABOUT AN APPEAL
ON THE RULES OF THIS HOUSE
PLEASE CONFINE YOUR COMMENTS TO.
THE RULING AND THE RULES OF THE
HOUSE DEGREE MISTER SPEAKER I'M
EXPLAINING WHY I WANT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES AND WHY I BELIEVE MY
MOTION WAS IN ORDER. IS IT WE
ARE IN AN URGENT CRISIS GAS
PRICES ARE OUT. OF THE SUBSTANCE
. STRICKEN WITH GRIEF NOW. YOUR
ADAM ORDERED MR GALLAGHER. YOU
MAY SPEAK TO THE RULES OF THE
HOUSE ON THIS APPEAL. SO AGAIN
I'M ASKING THAT WE SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX WHICH
ACTUALLY YOU GUYS OF ALREADY
DONE TODAY- AND YOU HAVE DONE
MANY TIMES IN THE PAST- TO IT OR
THAT WE CAN BRING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO THE FLOOR FOR A VOTE.
AND IF YOU VOTE YES YOU'RE
ASKING YOU ARE SAYING THAT YOU
WANT TO SUSPEND THE GAYS THE GAS
TAX FOR GALLAGHER- YOU'RE OUT OF
ORDER GALLAGHER.
MEMBERS WE WERE PROPERLY ON
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. WE
ARE GOING TO DOCTOR CHOI THIS IS
AC THIS IS. AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SIX FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE DR CHOI
. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI AND
OTHERS MACLAINE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DR CHOI. DR CHOI. HOLD
ON DR CHOI. DR SURE YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU SPEAKER AND
THE MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
THE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX. AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX IS AN
IMPORTANT MANAGER THAT WILL
ENSURE NINE CREDIT AND THE
DISABLED THE STUDENTS WALK ON
TENDING A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CAUGHT COLLEGES HAVE THE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THEIR STUDENT BODY ASSOCIATIONS
AND THE HAVE THE ABILITY TO RUN
FOR CHILDREN OF TRUSTEE. MANY
STUDENTS OUT WITH THE EXCEPTION
LEADS ARE ARE RECRUIT PRECLUDED
FROM PARTICIPATING IN THE STREET
ON BODY ASSOCIATIONS BECAUSE OF
THE ON MINIMUM UNIT THE
REQUIREMENTS. NOTED A IN THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION CODE
SECTION. SEVEN SIX ZERO SIX ONE
EIGHT. THIS HAS ALLOWED US SOME
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
ABILITY TO RISE THE UNIT AND-
GPA REQUIREMENTS SO TO ONE IN
OCTOBER LEVEL THAT HAS SOLD YOU
REDUCE THE ACCESS FOR STUDENTS
FOR ALL BACKGROUNDS TO
PARTICIPATE INDUSTRY RUN BY THE
ASSOCIATION SO. OR THE ABILITY
TO RUN FOR SHARON TRUSTY AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX PROVIDES A
DISABLED AND A NON CREDIT
STUDENTS UP ON. ALTERNATIVE A
METHOD OF- QUALIFYING FOR
CHILDREN COVER- IN THE HOPE THAT
THE DISKS ENCOURAGES A
PARTICIPATION IN THOSE CHILDREN
OF AMONG THE FOR ALL TYPES OF
THE STUDENTS ARE REMOVING
BARRIERS AND THE BECOMING MORE
INCLUSIVE. THIS ORDER RECEIPT OF
HIS HOUSE A RECEIVED A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN ASSEMBLY
ARE YOU EDUCATION COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR FIVE
WILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
CHOI SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE- STE.
STE. ALL MEMBERS REPRESENT ABOUT.
TECH WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
MISTER GRAYSON SPELL THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
SEVEN SIXTY NINE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON IN
EQUITY TO BUSINESSES AND DECLARE
THE URGENCY THERE UP THE CORRECT
IMMEDIATELY. MISTER GRAYSON YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS A. B. SEVEN SIXTY
NINE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
SENATE AMENDMENTS AT EMERGENCY
CLAUSE IN CERTAIN THE BILL'S
TIME FRAME I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GRAYSON SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLARK WELL
OVER THERE ALL. MEMBERS LETTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE YOUR
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SEVENTY KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
NOTES HERE ON THE MEASURE THAT
BILL PASSES. SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS. WE
ARE GOING TO CAN CHECK OUT OUR-
WE WILL MOVE TO THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR. THIS WILL BE A. WE
WILL NOW WAS. MEMBERS WE ARE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE WE
VOTE WILL FIRST TAKE OF ITEMS
THIRTY TO FORTY ONE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN RELATIVE TO
THAT HISTORY MONTH SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY BY
CYNICAL CHEESY RELATIVES OF
VISUAL AND PERFORMING ARTS
EDUCATION LAW. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY ONE BY CENTER
RUBIO AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS. AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY THREE BY CENTER RUBIO AND
OTHER TRUCKS WITH WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WEEK. MEMBERS THIS
IS FOR ADDING ON TO THE
RESOLUTION SIGNED CONSENT THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK LIBERAL
. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTIONS. YEAH THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS ON THE
RESOLUTIONS. CLERK WILL CLOSER
ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY. CO
AUTHORS ATTY WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ. THE SECOND I CAN
CHECK OUT OUR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN
RELATIVE TO THAT HISTORY MONTH.
LOCAL UP IN THE WRONG. SARAH ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. THE
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO CONSENT
CALENDARS ADOPTED. CLERK WILL
READ THEIR MANY ITEMS ON CONSENT
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN EIGHT TWO I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY ONE I. SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO INCIDENT CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY THREE I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO. MR FONG
PLEASE STAGE POINT OF ORDER. I
THINK THE SPEAKER MY POINT OF
ORDER AND I REQUEST THAT FOR
CLARIFICATION IS THAT UNDER RULE
EIGHTY TWO AT- AN APPEAL FROM
DECISION OF THE SPUR OF THE
CHAIR- CALLS FOR A VOTE SO I
WOULD ASK THAT A VOTE BE BE
TAKEN ON- ARE OUR LEADERS- CALL
FOR AT THE PEEL THE CHAIR.
MR FONG THE POINT OF ORDER IS
NOT WELL TAKEN YOU'LL RECALL.
THAT MR GALLAGHER WAS OUT OF
ORDER REPEATEDLY AND WE HAD
MOVED ON TO THE BUSINESS OF THE
HOUSE AT THAT TIME. MR FONG. BUT
I IT JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
THOUGH YOU RECOGNIZE AND ACT
AND- THE APPEAL SO IF THE DEAL
WAS RECOGNIZED WITH THERE NOT BE
A VOTE ON THAT APPEAL. MYSTERON
MR GALLAGHER WAS OUT OF ORDER
REPEATEDLY AND WE MOVED ON WITH
THE BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE SO THE
POINT WHERE IT'S NOT WELL TAKEN
. AND I RULED ON THE MATTER.
MR KILEY IS APPEALING THE RULING
OF THE CHAIR. THAT REQUIRES A
SECOND. SECONDED BY MR FONG. WE
HAVE TWO MINUTES. MR KILEY OF
TWO MINUTES SPECIFICALLY TO THE
RULING OF THE CHAIR. ON THE
RULES OF THE HOUSE AND THIS
PARLIAMENTARY MATTER. I THINK
HER FONG VERY CLEARLY EXPLAINED-
THAT THE CHAIR IS OVERTLY
BREAKING THE RULES OF THIS
CHAMBER IN ORDER TO SPARE
MEMBERS A VOTE ON AN ISSUE THAT
IS A PROFOUND IMPORTANCE TO
EVERY CALIFORNIAN I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ON THE APPEAL OF THE
CHAIR. MR COUNTY- ACTUALLY BE
ASKING FOR NOVA BECAUSE A
QUESTION BEFORE THE BODY IS. IS
THE RULING OF THE CHAIR TO BE
SUSTAINED. AND I HAVE MY TWO
MINUTES NOW MR KILEY. AND I HAVE
RULED ON THE MATTER. I HAVE
EXPLAINED THE RATIONALE THE
ORIGINAL MOTION TO WITHDRAW WAS
SENT TO THE RULES COMMITTEE. THE
BILL HI IN CHIEF HAD BEEN
PROPERLY REFERRED TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. WE
HAVE TRIED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE. AND
MR GALLAGHER WAS OUT OF ORDER
REPEATEDLY. TRYING TO SPEAK TO
THE SUBSTANCE OF THE MATTER WHEN
IT'S A PROCEDURAL MATTER. I HAVE
MADE MY RULING IN THIS MATTER
THE QUESTION FOR THE BODY YOU
SHALL THE DECISION OF THE CHAIR
BE SUSTAINED. MS RACES ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MR KILEY IS
ASKING FOR NOVA FOR GLOBAL ROLE. THIS RACE IS ASKING FOR IT I
FELT. I SHALL THE RULING OF THE
CHAIR BE SUSTAINED. MISTER
PATTIES ASKING FOR NO VOTE.
ASSEMBLY JORDY PRESENT AND
VOTING.
WELL I. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
EYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS EIGHTEEN
THE RULING OF THE CHAIR IS
SUSTAINED WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL THE CALL AT THIS TIME.
BEFORE WE GO TO ADJOURNMENTS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
GIVE RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES. WILL BE
SPEAKING ON ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
RESPECTFUL TENSIONER CALLING TO
RETURNING THE MEMORY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WOULD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. MS AGUILAR CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. SALLY
SCHMIDT CHEF RESTAURATEUR
COOKING TEACHER AND ONE OF THE
EARLIEST WOMEN CHEFS IN AMERICA
DIED IN HER HOME IN FEW LOW
CALIFORNIA ON SATURDAY MARCH
FIFTH JUST FIVE DAYS FROM HER
NINETIETH BIRTHDAY. HAILED AS A
PIONEER OF CALIFORNIA CUISINE
SALLY WAS CELEBRATED FOR FARM TO
TABLE A LOT OF A CORE OF
CHRISLEY OF CHRISLEY IN LONG
BEFORE THE TERMS WERE EVER USED
. SARAH ALSO KNOWN AS SALLY
KELSO WAS BORN FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH NINETEEN THIRTY TWO IN
ROSEVILLE THE DAUGHTER OF A
RURAL ROAD WORKER IN SCHOOL
TEACHER. SALLY TOOK TO THE
KITCHEN EARLY WHERE ONE OF HER
EARLIEST MEMORIES WAS STANDING
ON A STOOL AT OUR MOTHER STOVE
STIRRING THE CHOCOLATE PUDDING.
SHE GREW UP IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY WHERE HER FAMILY HAD
ENOUGH LAND TO GROW VEGETABLES
AND KEEP A COW. AS A CHILD SHE
CHURNED BUTTER CANNED VEGETABLES
AND MADE JIM. SHE GRADUATED
EARLY FROM HIGH SCHOOL AT THE
AGE OF SIXTEEN AND STUDIED HOME
ECONOMICS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS AND THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
GRADUATING IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY. SHE MET
HER HUSBAND ON. A AT A WEDDING
WHILE SHE WAS STILL UC DAVIS AND
THE PAIR CONTINUED TO CORRESPOND
AFTER HE ENLISTED IN THE AIR
FORCE. THEY WERE MARRIED IN JULY
OF NINETEEN FIFTY THREE AND
MOVED TO FRESNO WHERE DON HAD A
JOB IN BANKING. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN WITH FIVE CHILDREN
IN TOW THEY MOVED TO YOUNG BILL
IN THE NAPA VALLEY BEGINNING
THERE ALMOST THIRTY YEARS IN THE
NAPA'S RESTAURANTS COMMUNITY.
THEIR FIRST CHALLENGE BEGAN
MANAGING THE VINTAGE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY A HISTORIC WINERY
CONVERTED TO SHOPS GALLERIES AND
A CAFE. SALLY TOOK OVER RUNNING
MAKE CLEAR IT WAS REALLY A
HAMBURGER AND MILKSHAKE STAND.
WITH SALLY SUGGESTED
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE SHOP USING
ROMAINE. REMIND REMAIN ROMAINE
LETTUCE INSTEAD OF ICE BURKE IN
SHAPING BURGER PATTIES BY HAND
INSTEAD OF SMASHING THEM WITH A
LARGE CAN. SOME SAY SHE
DISMISSED THEM. OTHERS THAT HE
QUIT. EITHER WAY SALLY BECAME A
SHIFT. HER FAMOUSLY LONG LUNCH
LINES OF THE CAFE LED TO HER.
FOR HER TO FIND A SPACE AND OPEN
THE CHUTNEY KITCHEN. A FULL
SERVICE RESTAURANT WITH A
MONTHLY FRIDAY NIGHT PRICE FIX
DINNERS. OUR CUSTOMERS ENJOY THE
FIVE COURSE MEAL PAIRED WITH
NAPA VALLEY WINES A NEW MENU
EACH MONTH PLANTING COOKED FROM
SCRATCH BY CELL USING LOCAL AND
IN IN SEASON INGREDIENTS. THE
SCHMIDTS ALWAYS KEPT THE
BUSINESS IS SIMPLE AS THE FOOD
CASH YOUR CHECK WAS ALWAYS OF
ALL THE TOOK. BUT CUSTOMERS WERE
TRUSTED AND QUICKLY LEARNED IF
YOU NEITHER IF YOU HADN'T EITHER
NO PROBLEM THEY JUST MAIL THE
BILL TO YOUR HOME. YEARS LATER
THEIR SUCCESS LED TO THE
RENOVATE A RUNDOWN OLD STONE
BUILDING A FORMER SALOON
CONVERTED TO A LAUNDRY AND THEN
BOARDING HOUSE. SELLING IN DONE
SPENT SEVERAL YEARS REBUILDING A
SPACE THAT WOULD BECOME THE
FAMOUS FRENCH LAUNDRY. THEY
SERVE DINNER ON A NIGHTLY BASIS
ALWAYS WITH LOCAL NAPA WINES
UNTIL NINETEEN NINETY FOUR WHEN
THEY SOLD IT TO UP AND COMING
CHEF THOMAS KELLER. MANY OF SAID
THE SELLING NEVER LIKE BEING IN
THE SPOTLIGHT. IN A RESTAURANT
SHE REFUSED TO GO INTO THE
DINING ROOM DURING DINING
SERVICES TO RECEIVE COMPLIMENTS.
BUT ALWAYS WELCOME THOSE
INTERESTED IN SPEAKING WITH HER
TO COME TO THE KITCHEN. SALLY
WAS A TRUE PIONEER AND INFLUENCE
THE FUTURE OF CUISINE IN THE
NAPA VALLEY. SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER SISTER CASE STONE OF SANTA
CRUZ CHILDREN KATHY HOFFMAN OF
WILLIAMS OREGON JOHNNY SCHMIDT A
BOONVILLE KAREN BASS OF FILO.
ERIC SCHMIDT OF NAPA AND TERRY
SCHMIDT OF SEBASTOPOL TEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND FIVE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
SALLY SMITH. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY AND DOCTOR WOULD ON
THIS GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE THE JOURNEY OF SALLY
SCHMIDT. FOLLOWING THE SALE OF
HER AWARD WINNING RESTAURANT
SALLY AND DON BECAME RESIDENTS
OF MENDOCINO COUNTY FOR ANOTHER
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS. THEY
RETIRED TO THE APPLE FARM A
THIRTY ACRE FARM THE PURCHASE IN
MENDOCINO IS ANDERSON VALLEY
NEARLY A DECADE BEFORE. NEVER
REALLY RETIRED SALLY OPENED A
BED AND BREAKFAST AND OFFER
COOKING CLASSES FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS ALONGSIDE HER DAUGHTER
KAREN BATES. STUDENTS CAME FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD TO COOK WITH
HER. NOW THE FARM IS A HUB FOR
THE ENTIRE FAMILY WITH MULTIPLE
FAMILY MEMBERS ACROSS
GENERATIONS LIVING THERE. A
SECOND RETIREMENT BEGAN WHEN DON
AND SALLY RETREATED TO THEIR
COTTAGE IN ELK BY THE NAVARRO
RIVER WHERE SHE LEARNED TO COOK
FOR TOO AGAIN. THIS IS WHERE SHE
BEGAN THINKING ABOUT WRITING A
BOOK FOR HER FAMILY OUR STUDENTS
AND TO EVERYONE WHO LOVED HER
COOKING. EIGHT YEARS LATER THEY
RETURNED TO THE APPLE FARM SO
THEY CAN BE CLOSE TO FAMILY.
FOLLOWING THE LOSS OF HER
HUSBAND DON IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SALLY WENT TO WORK BEGINNING A
TEN YEAR PROCESS- UP TO RECORD
THE STORIES AND RECIPES SHE
WANTED TO LEAVE BEHIND FOR HER
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. STAYING TRUE
TO FORM AND NOT WANTING TO BE IN
THE SPOTLIGHT SALLY MADE HER
DEPARTURE WHEN SHE WAS FINISHED
WHAT SHE WANTED TO DO BUT BEFORE
SHE HAD TIME HAD TO HAVE THE
SPOTLIGHT SHINED DOWN ON HER.
SHE DIED BEFORE THE PUBLICATION
OF HER BOOK SIX CALIFORNIA
KITCHENS WHICH IS BEING RELEASED
ON APRIL FIFTH. IT TAKES US TO
THE SIX KITCHENS WHERE SHE
LEARNED TO COOK. IN HER BOOK HER
RECIPES ARE PUBLISHED AND SHE
WROTE THEM ALWAYS METICULOUSLY
BY HAND AND INTO STYLE WITH THE
INGREDIENTS LISTED ON THE RIGHT
AND THE DIRECTIONS FOR THOSE.
INGREDIENTS NEXT TO THEM ON THE
LEFT. IN THE BOOK SHE WROTE ALL
IN ALL I REALLY HAVE DONE JUST
WHAT I LOVE TO DO. WHICH IS
ALWAYS BEEN SIMPLY TO COOK GOOD
FOOD FOR THOSE I CARED FOR
THAT'S WHAT MATTERED THAT'S- ALL
THAT MATTERED. RANSON PERRY
HOFFMAN IS A MICHELIN STARRED
CHEF AND RUNS THE BOONVILLE
HOTEL AND RESTAURANT WAS SALLY
SON JOHNNY SCHMIDT. HE SAID HE
LEARNED MUCH FROM HIS
GRANDMOTHER HE SAID LIFE AND HER
FAMILY WAS SO MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT IN THE KITCHEN SHE
WORKED IN AS MUCH AS YOU LOVE
THEM. I'M CONSTANTLY INSPIRED OF
TO FIND MORE BALANCE IN MY OWN
LIFE BECAUSE SHE DID IT SO WELL.
SALLY MADE QUITE AN IMPACT NOT
ONLY IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT
AROUND THE WORLD I ASKED WE
ADJOURNED TODAY IN SALLY'S
MEMORY. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
DR QUIRK. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR JOURNEY MEMORY.
THANK YOU SPEAKER. TERRY
SANDOVAL WAS BORN ON JULY
THIRTEENTH NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
IN LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA. SHE
LOVED HER MOM RAMONA ORTIZ
DEARLY AS YOUR MOM'S ALZHEIMER'S
PROGRESSED TERRY MOVED THE
FAMILY TO THE OAKLAND HILLS TO
BE WITH HER. AND PROVIDE FULL
TIME CARE. IN ADDITION TO
MAINTAINING ALL OF FOR POLITICAL
COMMITMENTS. TERRY WAS A LONG
TIME LABOR AND POLITICAL LEADER
IN THE EAST BAY BEGINNING HER
CAREER WITH OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL THREE AT A TIME WHEN THERE
WERE FEW WOMEN LEADERS IN THE
BUILDING TRADES. SHE WORKED AS A
CAMPAIGN MANAGER FOR BALLOT
MEASURES IN VARIOUS CANDIDATES
FOR LOCAL AND STATE OFFICE.
TERRY WAS A SKILLED ELECTORAL
CAMPAIGNER WHO BUILD STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS USED HER EXPERIENCE TO
MENTOR OTHERS TO MAKE AN IMPACT
ON THE LIVES OF WORKING. PEOPLE
I FIRST MET TERRY IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO WHEN WE HELPED
TRINITAS ABSENT A BLACK WOMAN
GET ELECTED AS A JUDGE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. TERRY DEDICATED
THE LAST DECADE OF HER LIFE TO
SERVING WORKING PEOPLE SHE
SERVED AS POLITICAL DIRECTOR OF
VARIOUS UNIONS AS THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE ALAMEDA LABOR
COUNCIL. OVER THE LAST YEAR
TERRY WAS THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE ORGANIZER AT THE
KAISER FACILITIES IN SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO AND REDWOOD CITY. AND
WAS HONORED TO SERVE AS CHAIR OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. TERRY PASSED AWAY ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SHE WAS HAPPILY
MARRIED FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS
TO JOHN ABSOLUTELY ADORED HER
SON JOSEPH WHOSE RECENT
GRADUATION FOR COLLEGE FROM
COLLEGE SHE WAS VERY PROUD OF.
HER FAVORITE MUSIC ARTISTS WERE
LADY GAGA LIZZO COLDPLAY PRINCE
PITBULL AND EARTH WIND AND FIRE.
SHE LOVED HUMMINGBIRDS WHICH
REMINDED HER OF HER MOTHER SHE
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO EMPOWER
WORKERS TO TAKE ACTION AND TOUCH
THE LIVES OF MANY PEOPLE.
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND JOHN SON
JOSEPH SISTER MARIA BROTHER TONY
AND A HOST OF FAMILY AND FRIENDS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR CORK.
AND MS BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
SHERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO GERMAN
IN THE MEMORY OF ONE IT TERRY
SEND OF ALL WHO WAS ONE OF THE
FIERCEST ADVOCATES FOR WORKING
FAMILIES I HAVE EVER MET. ANYONE
WANTING TO GET INVOLVED IN
ANYTHING POLITICAL HAS TEARS
NUMBER ON SPEED DIAL. SHE WAS A
TRUE ACTIVIST SHE WAS A JOY SHE
WAS THE HEART OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND OF THE LABOR MOVEMENT
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY. SHE WAS A
LABOR LEADER A MENTOR AND A
FRIEND. AND A MOTHER SEOUL
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF HER SON AND
HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS. I WAS
STRONG IN YOUR CONVICTIONS AND
RELENTLESS IN PURSUING WHAT SHE
FELT WAS JUST BUT WAS ALSO
EXTREMELY KIND AND HONEST. MANY
REMARKED ON HOW WHEN YOU WALKED
INTO A ROOM AND YOU WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO FIND A PLACE OF SOLACE
YOU WOULD GO TO TERRY SANDOVAL.
PASSING LEAVES A HUGE GAP IN THE
ALAMEDA LABOR MOVEMENTS IN THE
ALAMEDA DEMOCRATIC PARTY. BUT
HER LEGACY WILL LIVE ON IN ALL
OF THE WORK SHE DID TO RAISE UP
OTHERS. IN IN HER HONOR I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF TERRY
SANDOVAL. THE NEW A TERRY
SANDOVAL. ISSUE REST IN POWER.
THANK YOU MS BONTA AND MS WICKS
. THIS WICKS YEAH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I ASKED
WE ALSO ADJOURNED AND THE MEMORY
OF TERRY SANDOVAL. HE WAS
THOUGHT JERRY WAS KNOWN
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AS A
TIRELESS CHAMPION FOR ORGANIZED
LABOR A LEADER IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN CHILDREN AND WORKING
FAMILIES. TERRY WORKED FOR MANY
YEARS AS AN OPERATING ENGINEER
BACK WHEN THERE WEREN'T MANY
WOMEN DOING THOSE JOBS SHE SHE
WORKED BIG OPERATING EARTH
MOVING MACHINES. ON CONSTRUCTION
SITES AS A LABOR ORGANIZER SHE
FOUGHT FOR MORE EQUITABLE
WORKPLACES FOR WOMEN AND WORKING
FAMILIES. WHEN SHE AND HER
BELOVED SON JOSEPH. WHEN SHE HAD
HER BELOVED SON SHE WOULD BRING
HIM TO CAMPAIGN MEETINGS AND
EVENTS AND SHE WAS VERY PROUD TO
BE HIS MOTHER THIS IS SOMETHING
I CAN RELATE TO. TERRY WAS THE
FIRST LATINA BOARD MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S POLITICAL
CAUCUS WHERE SHE WORKED TO GET
MORE PRO CHOICE WOMEN AND WOMEN
OF COLOR INTO ELECTIVE OFFICE
SHE WAS A LEADER IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY LABOR COUNCIL AND S. U.
U. H. W. AND MOST RECENTLY AT
THE CHAIR OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. SHE WAS A
LOYAL FRIEND TO MANY A MENTOR TO
COUNTLESS ORGANIZER'S AND A
FEARLESS ADVOCATE FOR HER
COMMUNITY. SHE ALWAYS WORKED
WITH SUCH KINDNESS AND GRACE AND
I WILL SAY IN MY RACE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. I DIDN'T HAVE A CA USE
INDOORS MEANT IT WAS A VERY
CONTENTIOUS RACE AND WE ARE ON
OPPOSITE SIDES IN THAT RACE. AND
THE RACE GOT HEATED AND IT WAS
VERY POLITICAL. AND FRANKLY
SOMETIMES IT GOT A LITTLE UGLY.
AND TERRY WAS ONE OF THE FEW
PEOPLE WHO REALLY SHOWED SUCH
GRACE AND RESPECT AND FRIENDSHIP
TO ME EVEN THOUGH. S. YEAH YOU
HADN'T ENDORSED ME. AND I THINK
IT SPEAKS TO HER CHARACTER SHE
KNEW THAT THERE WAS MORE THAT
UNITES US THAN DIVIDES US. AND
IN THESE MOMENTS OF POLITICAL
FIGHTS ESPECIALLY WITH DEMOCRAT
VERSUS DEMOCRAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO REMEMBER
THESE THINGS AND SHE REALLY
EMBODIED THAT. AS A PERSON AND
SHE KNEW THAT WE WOULD WORK
TOGETHER IN COMMON PURPOSE THAT
WE WOULD WORK ON THINGS
TOGETHER. AND I LET MY SUPPORT
WHEN SHE WAS THE ORGANIZING
KAISER WORKERS FOR BETTER
CONTRACT. AND SHE HELPED ME PASS
A BILL LAST YEAR- THE RACE AND
HEALTH CARE TRANSPARENCY ACT.
AND SO WE DID WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TOGETHER I THINK
THAT SPEAKS TO WHO SHE IS AS A
PERSON. SHE WILL BE TERRIBLY
MISSED A GREAT MOTHER A GREAT
LEADER A GREAT UNION ORGANIZER A
GREAT LEADERIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY I ASKED THE RETURN AND THE
MEMORY OF TERRY SANDOVAL. THANK
YOU MISS WICKS AND MR KALRA YOU
TWO ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE- DONE A
WONDERFUL JOB OF. TALKING ABOUT-
TERRY'S BACKGROUND AS WELL AS
WHAT AN INCREDIBLE FEARS
CHAMPION FOR WORKERS SHE WAS-
AND BEING FIERCE AND BEING
COMPASSIONATE AND HUMBLE AND FUN
HUH IN SHOULD ALWAYS LIGHT UP A
ROOM- AND SHE ALWAYS PUT HER
MEMBERS BEFORE HER- AND- I JUST.
THINK YOU CAN PROBABLY TELL BY
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS SPEAKING AND
HOW CLOSE SO MANY OF US WERE TO
HER. SHE'S GOING TO BE DEARLY
MISSED AND I REALLY WANT TO
OFFER MY CONDOLENCES TO HER
HUSBAND JOHN AND HER SON JOSEPH-
I KNOW HOW PROUD HER FAMILY WAS
OF HER AS MUCH AS SHE WAS PROUD
OF HER FAMILY BOTH- HERB- SOME
FAMILY AS WELL AS HER LABOR
FAMILY AND I THINK THAT- IF WE
ALL COULD JUST WORK IN THE
SPIRIT OF THAT SHE BROUGHT TO
HER WORK WE WOULD ALL BE BETTER
OFF. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA. AND MISTER SPEAKER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY T ASK THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF SAM
SAX ONE OF THE PRIVILEGES OF OUR
POSITION AS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET REMARKABLE PEOPLE RARELY
HOWEVER HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MEETSOMEONE OF THE CALIBRE
OF SAM SAX. SAM WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN AND JOINED U.
S. ARMY AT THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN
SAN FOUGHT AGAINST THE **** IN
WORLD WAR TWO PARTICIPATING IN
THE D. DAY INVASION OF NORMANDY
AND THE LIBERATION OF THE ****
CONCENTRATION CAMPS HE WAS A
HERO BEFORE MOST OF US WERE EVEN
BORN. FOLLOWING HIS MILITARY
SERVICE SAM WAS A TEACHER IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS AS
YOU ALL KNOW ANOTHER KIND OF
HERO TO ME AND TO ALL OF US.
EVEN WHILE TURNING A HUNDRED AND
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HE WOULD
RECALL DETAILS OF THE FIGHT
AGAINST FASCISM. WAS A STARK
REMINDER THAT WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO OPPOSE THE WOULD BE DICTATORS
AROUND THE WORLD. AND HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES. I HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO HONOR SACHS SAM SAX
A NUMBER OF TIMES SINCE I BECAME
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND I'M
DEEPLY SADDENED BY HIS LOSS. I
AND THE MEMBERS OF MY STAFF MY
DISTRICT STAFF IN PARTICULAR.
TREASURE THE TIMES WE WERE ABLE
TO INTERACT WITH HIM. SAMM SACKS
DIED MARCH FOURTEENTH JUST A BIT
MORE THAN A MONTH SHY OF WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN HIS HUNDRED
SEVENTH BIRTHDAY. HE IS SURVIVED
BY THREE SONS HOWARD ALAN LARRY
J. AND ROBERT LEE. AND BY FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN I ASKED WE
ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
A GREAT MAN. SAMM SACKS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
PLEASE BE THE NAME SUGGESTS WE
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL REQUEST
RICHARD IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
. MEMBERS I'M ORDERING THE
DEATHS REMAIN OPEN TO PROCESS
BUSINESS THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH TWENTY
FIFTH NO FLOOR SESSION- CHECK IN
SESSION. MONDAY MARCH TWENTY
EIGHTH FLOOR SESSIONS AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS OF REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN A MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING A FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. THE SERRANO SO SINISTER
DR ARAMBULA SECONDS. THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH AT
ONE PM WE ARE TURNED.